[Música]
bienvenidos a una nueva emisión de
reporteros de las 24 comenzamos
siguiendo el ejemplo de la activista
sueca greta thunberg muchos jóvenes
franceses también se están movilizando
por el medio ambiente una lucha por un
mundo más verde responsable y justo con
marchas y acciones anti publicitarias y
haciendo uso de las redes sociales
quieren interpelar al gobierno y a la
opinión pública sobre la emergencia
medioambiental y social y sobre los
modos de consumo pretenden dar ejemplo y
cambiar la mentalidad de comportamiento
con soluciones para cambiar su entorno
con la esperanza de crear un mundo mejor
quiénes son estos ecologistas jóvenes
que se mueven por el planeta cuáles son
sus motivaciones en qué se diferencian
de los activistas con experiencias las
respuestas en la siguiente historia de
carl y nación
[Música]
cada vez que puede sacha viene a
ayudarle a dominique a cuidar de sus
animales en el corazón de borgoña
tenemos que agarrarla porque tiene un
problema en la ubre este parisino de 19
años defiende la causa animal no hay
nada más inocente que un animal y les
hacemos mucho daño los matamos para
comernos los y no se merecen en absoluto
que los tratemos así solo tenemos que
darles la libertad que se merecen y eso
es lo que tienen en el santuario el
santuario está ahí para darles un
respiro
dominique dirige el santuario el mayor
santuario de animales de granja en
francia aquí 800 animales ovejas en su
mayoría viven en relativa libertad en
100 hectáreas la mayoría de ellos fueron
abandonados o entregados por criadores
asociaciones o individuos el santuario
funciona gracias a las donaciones por lo
tanto toda ayuda es bienvenida corro más
despacio con mi rodilla y para atrapar
un animal es mejor día dos personas
estos son pequeños pero cuando hay un
carnero que pesa 80 o 100 kilos no es lo
mismo si estoy sola
aprovecho cuando ya está acá y cuando se
va a quedar sustos
[Risas]
tatxan se volvió vegano hace cinco años
le indignaban las condiciones de crianza
y de sacrificio de los animales de
granja no come carne pescado ni ningún
producto animal hizo de su amor por los
animales un combate
y muchísimo de todos esos animales
detrás de mí no estarían acá si no nos
hubiéramos salvado de los mataderos
esto les permite tener una vida natural
como debería ser
es decir en paz con los suyos y no
degollados
dominica solía ser criador al igual que
esa ahora anhela un mundo sin pesca caza
o incluso agricultura todo el nombre de
una proclamada igualdad entre especies
deberíamos dejar que el criador elija
que elija a decir sigo criando ganado
tradicionalmente o me convierto en
paisajista
es decir sigo cuidando a los animales
para que cuiden la tierra o simplemente
los tengo como si fuera un gran
zoológico
porque no sería un mundo fantástico
ese es nuestro sueño
salsa quiere creer en este mundo ideal
para financiar refugios como este estos
nuevos activistas esperan algún día
poder contar con ayudas europeas
mientras tanto la liberación animal ya
tiene su himno y su vídeo
[Música]
aquí vemos activistas estadounidenses
tomando una carnicería y sacando a las
gallinas de sus jaulas
[Música]
lo que es genial es que todos son
jóvenes míralos
los jóvenes son quienes van a cambiar el
futuro no tienen que darse por vencidos
[Aplausos]
de vuelta en parís
nos encargamos del sahara
para estos jóvenes activistas los
derechos humanos y el clima son la misma
lucha se preparan para una operación de
etiquetado solo tenemos que ver a dónde
vamos porque no están todas las marcas
su objetivo son las 83 marcas que fueron
puestas al descubierto por un estudio
australiano
la idea es alertar a los consumidores
señalando las marcas cuyos productos
serían el resultado del trabajo forzado
de los uigures una minoría musulmana
perseguida en china
[Música]
durante dos horas ponen sus etiquetas en
los productos y pasan algunos gustos en
el proceso
[Música]
cuántas etiquetas pusieron 4 567
me asusté con la última porque la chica
te estaba mirando justo cuando la estaba
exponiendo corren el riesgo de ser
demandados por degradación o difamación
y que piensa en tus papás de esto
prefiero no responder a esa pregunta en
mi caso mi mamá me apoya totalmente
de eso es genial
cuántos años tienes tengo 21 ok aunque
cuando estuve tenía no estaba tan feliz
jessica por su parte tiene 17 años
nuestro movimiento se basa en el hecho
de que no podemos resolver todo lo
social sin resolver todo lo ambiental y
viceversa
[Música]
desde hace años que se han hecho
manifestaciones y no han logrado hacer
una diferencia y ahora a nivel ecológico
tenemos que actuar hay una verdadera
emergencia para mí la desobediencia
civil es un medio debemos presionar más
a los grupos a la comunidad hace una
semana que estamos haciendo esto y como
resultado siete mil personas más sale en
la cuenta de juventud por el clima
juventud por el clima un colectivo
inspirado por la activista sueca greta
tandberg jessica se unió al grupo el
pasado mes de mayo pero su compromiso
contra la moda rápida viene de antes
ahora estoy haciendo un top para una
amiga mía todo lo que hice fue un
poco de tela de un vestido x un top con
locos y aquí y luego lo que sería camino
la colegiala aprovecho el confinamiento
para rehacer parte de su vestuario su
ropa es toda de segunda mano o casi
esta es una chaqueta de cuero que compré
en una venta de garaje por 10 euros
esta es una chaqueta que tengo de cuando
solía comprar moda rápida así que es de
sara pero ya no compensará por supuesto
como resultado de su activismo jessica
también decidió cambiar de rumbo en sus
estudios
solía querer trabajar en la moda para
ser marketing pero en el último minuto
cambió de opinión porque vi la película
minimalista y me di cuenta de que no
podía apoyar este sistema de consumo
excesivo para defender la causa difunde
sus creaciones entre sus suscriptores
según ella es difícil prescindir de las
redes sociales a pesar de que éstas
consuman mucha energía
si no tenemos esa comunicación a escala
global entonces no podemos detener el
problema no podemos actuar concretamente
jessica no es la única que ha cambiado
sus costumbres y compartido su
experiencia camille y solar decidieron
dejar de viajar en avión desde hace un
año y medio este es el sombrerito y
vamos a seleccionar nuestro destino con
camino
es cierto también
tengo mucho miedo
saca 12
a subir al volcán más alto de francia
estos estudiantes de 22 y 24 años
publican los vídeos de su travesía en
las redes sociales y nos vamos tenemos 5
días también esperamos darle ganas a la
gente de irse ocasiones en francia sin
avión sin dinero simplemente así sin
planearlo va a ser genial
la primera etapa antes de los volcanes
de govern ya es salir de parís cuestión
de unos pocos minutos nos van a ayudar
es muy amable nos salvó la vida de
viajar pidiendo un aventón dormir en la
casa de alguien
[Música]
para cam y la decisión de dejar de
viajar en avión nos surgió después de
calcular su huella ecológica
casi no comía carne no compraba ropa
nueva hacía mi mayor esfuerzo y aún así
necesitaba dos planetas para vivir
tantos como un estadounidense promedio y
me parece una locura porque pensaba
estar del lado correcto y quitando los
viajes en avión que hacía unas cuantas
veces al año me di cuenta de que no
necesitaba más que un planeta así que me
dije bueno no más abierto
el segundo paso es encontrar un lugar
para dejar sus maletas antes del ascenso
este residente local nos ayudará les
ofrece llevarlos al punto de partida de
la caminata
cada vez hay más y más pero creo que
tienen razón los apoyo al 1000% no es
fácil
sería complicado hacer lo que hacen con
digamos dos niños pequeños
[Música]
los viajes en avión son responsables del
3 al 5 de las emisiones globales de co2
con sus imágenes y miles de vistas en
las redes sociales
camille y solar quieren mostrar que
existe otra forma de viajar más limpia e
incluso más gratificante
[Música]
ellos no tuvieron la suerte de irse de
vacaciones
así que para mantenerse ocupados y
concientizar a los jóvenes sobre las
buenas costumbres ecológicas las llenas
un poco así
ibrahim organiza jornadas de limpieza es
voluntario en una asociación
te voy a ayudar a llenar tu bolsa veo
que te cuesta ver una cena esté bien
galán estuvo en el primer desafío de
limpieza que hicimos te acuerdas hagan
si estuvo bien y después los otros
barrios hicieron lo mismo que asientos o
todo
aquí la batalla por el planeta se libra
en las calles
tenemos que hacerlo o si no nadie lo
hará por nosotros
gas
la gente critica mucho awards es una de
las ciudades más pobres de este
departamento tenemos que cambiar la
imagen que la gente tiene de nosotros
limpiando la ciudad y también haciendo
otras cosas y lo primero que hay que
hacer es limpiar es por eso que recojo
la basura me parece que deberían poner
más basureros por ejemplo en esta casa
no hay niños pero les importa un comino
botar la basura del piso de todas
maneras no se acaban de tomar sus
bebidas cuando ya están botando las
latas por encima de la cerca
vamos chicos tenemos que cerrar las
bolsas cierren las bolsas por favor al
mezclar jóvenes de diferentes barrios
estas jornadas de limpieza han ayudado a
aliviar las tensiones
los dos barrios se entendieron que no
sirve de nada pelearse por un bar de la
ciudad que está en calma ya no hay riñas
todos pueden ir a donde quieran antes no
se podía ir a otro barrio ahora se puede
ahora podemos ponerlo en nuestro
currículum los jefes de las empresas
pueden decir ah hiciste el desafío de
limpieza escuché a hablar de eso en la
tele en otros países así que es un
orgullo también es un orgullo que se
hable de nuestra ciudad positivamente
exacto ahora estamos orgullosos de
nuestro barrio
estaba mejor en su casa
este tipo de acciones son repetidas en
otras ciudades de francia
salsa termino de ocuparse de las ovejas
de vuelta en parís hace sus compras en
esta tienda especializada en productos
veganos este es queso como para fondue
sirve para hacer gratinado si se parece
mucho al queso de verdad esto esto fu
con ajo de oso y tiene muchas proteínas
así que es interesante desde el punto de
vista nutricional según el tener una
dieta vegana es fácil no es muy costoso
y es bueno para el medio ambiente aunque
con algunos problemas en francia-
lamentablemente todavía no hay muchas
alternativas que sean realmente locales
así que si queremos productos de calidad
bueno ya precios razonables
lamentablemente no hay todavía una
verdadera oferta local
en su casa todos se volvieron
vegetarianos debido a su influencia su
madre es la única que todavía come
pescado en el menú de hoy ensalada taxi
flet vegetariana salchicha vegetariana y
otras alternativas a la carne que es
estos dos con ajo de oso eso me lo como
sí pero el estilo de vida de sacha no
siempre fue aceptado por sus padres para
obtener su aprobación
sacha primero tuvo que ir a ver a un
médico tenían la idea de que al volverme
belga no tendría deficiencias de
proteínas calcio hierro y fue una lucha
durante mucho tiempo en la familia y
recuerdo que el debate que tuvimos fue
muy duro pero entiendo entiendo a los
padres tuvo que convencerlos porque
fuimos educados con esa idea pero nos
dijimos que tal vez será una fase y de
hecho fue todo lo contrario y además nos
convenció
empezaste a ser vegano cuando tenías 14
yo tenía 11 cuando tienes 11 años como
es carne y tu hermano mayor te dice
estás comiendo cadáveres no te dan
muchas ganas de escucharlo pero lo
repetía tanto que después de un tiempo
nos interesamos y entendimos que tenían
razón al principio era mucho más
agresivo porque cuando descubres una
verdad que está escondida quieres
gritarlo a los cuatro vientos quieres
que la gente tenga ese epifanía que
tienes cuando te vuelves vegano y tratar
de hacer que el mundo se vuelva verano
lo más rápido posible por los animales
al igual que ellos cada vez más
adolescentes están dejando de comer
carles la cuestión de la bienestar de
los animales se ha convertido en una
parte importante del debate nacional y
las vacaciones de cami llegaron a su fin
a su regreso a gobernar la activista fue
invitada a participar en el debate en la
universidad de verano de mdc el
movimiento de empresas de francia frente
a unos empresarios que están lejos de
simpatizar con su causa
cammie y critica un modelo de
crecimiento que es nefasto para el
planeta y para la humanidad
creo que el mundo empresarial actual
está cansado al igual que la democracia
y la política y tenemos que atrevernos a
reinventar todo eso tal vez eso
signifique trabajar menos por un bien
más grande
depende de ustedes
este es el medio para gmt
así que la cuestión de trabajar menos no
es muy atractivo
[Aplausos]
y saben cuántas personas mueren por la
contaminación del aire cada año
50.000 no tengo las cifras presentes
pero son unos 30 o 40 mil así que esto
nos concierne a todos
un choque de culturas que llamará la
atención de los medios de comunicación y
las redes sociales
este año camí y suspenderá sus estudios
para dedicarse plenamente al activismo
por el medio ambiente
[Música]
a pesar de todo estos jóvenes activistas
pretenden dar ejemplo y crear cambios
reales
[Música]
gracias por acompañarnos en esta emisión
de reporteros recuerde que puede
ingresar a nuestra página web
tras 24 puntos para ver esta emisión y
también las anteriores hasta la próxima
semana
[Música]